[Musique]
la fièvre nom des douleurs abdominales
ah oui de violentes crampes d'estomac
vous avez été empoisonné par quoi barlow
c'est l'eau qui vous a empoisonné
oui c'est l'eau sur ma famille quatre
personnes ont été empoisonnés je vous
jure cette eau est en train de nous tuer
année dernière on a dit que l'eau
potable avaient commencé à couler non
non je n'ai fait que l'essayer j'en
écoutais comme ça je n'en n'ai même pas
vu ces [ __ ] de bassorah c'est ce qui
colle des tuyaux la même les animaux n'y
toucherai pas regarder cette couleur
blanche
ce n'est pas naturel l'esa pu vraiment
l'air de bassora où dans le monde trouve
tout un endroit où trois millions de
barils de pétrole sont pompées par jour
et où l'eau et de cette qualité
[Musique]
voyez vous même ces lots de bassorah
regard d'un poisson vos enfants nagent
dans cette eau vous voulez avec des
cheveux avec regarder sévère je dois
nettoyer ça tous les jours
[Musique]
vous avez des filtres dans votre
réservoir mais ça n'a pas aidé bien sûr
nous avons utilisé du chlore et tout ce
qu'il faut
rien n'a fonctionné les filtres ne
suffisent pas pour nettoyer l'eau de
basra de ces produits dangereux
[Musique]
nous avons entre 500 et 600 patients
chaque jour c'est mon frère nous n'avons
pas pu l'amener ici la nuit dernière car
les manifestants bloquer le pont à la
révolution de bassorah par des
révolutionnaires
[Applaudissements]
nous ne voulons ni pouvoir ni autre
fonction nous ne voulons qu'un verre
d'eau pour nos enfants et nous mêmes
nous ne voulons qu'à voir de l'eau à
boire
nous ne voulons que des droits basiques
l'eau et l'électricité rien d'autre
[Applaudissements]
ces genres de bassorah les gens du sud
ces révoltes poids serait relative parce
qu'il n'y a pas de service public
le gouvernement ne donne rien jusqu'à
présent cinq d'entre nous ont été tués
et des blessés
il est blessé ou des voix c'est un
tireur d'élite qui a fait ça
nous les vendrons tous nous sommes le
peuple de bassorah nous allons commencer
une révolution et elle se poursuivra
tant que nous n'aurons pas débarrassé
bassorah et tout l'irak deux le sang de
nos martyrs et notre bénédiction
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
centre de notre monde se trouve le moyen
orient et d'ailleurs la terre en titre
qu'est ce qui motive le pays est
traversé par deux grands fleuves avec le
stand le tigre et l'euphrate riche et
fertile
grâce à leur peau cette plaine a donné
naissance aux premières civilisations
humaines connues l'irak a été béni par
le tigre et l'euphrate des sommes un
pays qui a traditionnellement souffert
d'un excédent de bassorah se trouve à
l'embouchure du tigre et de l'euphrate
bassorah et est située sur la route de
la soie c'était la seule ville où l'on
voyait des étrangers au quotidien qu'il
travaille au port ou dans l'industrie
pétrolière
nestlé ici se trouve le grand port de
bassorah au carrefour du commerce
mondial des générations de marins ont
fait escale et les fables de simbad le
marin se base sur les histoires qu'il
racontait
on verra le sud de l'irak a été dévastée
par la guerre avec l'iran puis par les
sanctions
en 76 77 j'étais étudiant à la faculté
d'ingéniérie de bassorah votre belle
bassorah les étudiants des universités
irakienne ou qui était gratuite ce qui
était super où devait servir le
gouvernement pour chaque année d'étude
accompli et ça me paraissait juste à la
fin de la deuxième année ils m'ont dit
rétroactivement tu nous devra huit ans
au moment où tu auras ton diplôme je me
suis dit ah non ça suffit j'arrête
il valait mieux aller en amérique
obtenir un diplôme universitaire là bas
puis revenir faire deux ans à l'armée et
être libre et c'est ce que j'ai fait je
suis parti aux états unis
saddam est officiellement devenu
président en 1979
le plus drôle c'est que nous étions tous
fiers de lui un beau jeune homme
intelligent plein d'énergie et qui
nationalisé le pétrole
[Applaudissements]
même moi c'était bizarre
[Musique]
à
eauze elle a été en guerre pense dans le
presque toute sa présidence
quand j'ai eu mon diplôme la guerre iran
irak a commencé
[Applaudissements]
ps j'ai fait ma thèse et la guerre iran
irak n'était toujours pas terminé alors
il a fait la guerre entre 81 et 88
ban moindre il y a eu le koweït en outre
90 cet été
[Musique]
stan est renvoyée navteq aurait tout
d'épaisseur réalisé en semaine et vous
êtes un modèle parmi les fleurs au
réchauffement nérac a été sous le coup
de sanctions pendant 13 ans
on
m
je
[Musique]
j'ai donc vécu en dehors d'irak pendant
25 ans et puis j'y suis revenu en 2003
pour travailler sur des questions
environnementales
[Applaudissements]
cet endroit était entouré de forêt de
palmiers regarde regarde regarde tout
est bouché là bas c'est comme ça partout
à mon retour en 2003 j'étais vraiment
sous le choc
c'était presque comme recevoir un vrai
compte cet endroit n'avait aucun rapport
avec ce à quoi il ressemblait dans ma
mémoire
auparavant c'était le tout le monde de
bassorah et il est désormais bouché
comme une artère obstruée
[Musique]
et personne ne s'en soucie pas même les
habitants
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les gens ne se comporte pas comme si
c'était leur rue vous terminez une
bouteille et vous la jetée c'est comme
s'ils n'avaient pas de sentiment
d'appartenance à ce pays donc dans un
sens ou l'environnement n'est pas un
sujet de préoccupation pour eux on est
relié à la nature par le tigre et
l'euphrate pour pianoter malheureusement
toutes les villes du bassin du tigre et
de l'euphrate déversent leurs eaux usées
dans ces deux rivières bien fonctionné
pendant des milliers d'années
d'abord parce qu'il y avait peu de
déchet ensuite parce qu'il y avait
beaucoup d'eau à partir de 92 et la
turquie a construit 22 grands barrages
en amont sur l'euphrate et le tigre qui
la turquie contrôle 60% du cours
supérieur du tigre et environ 95 à 97 %
de celui de l'euphrate
[Musique]
en raison du manque d'eau la quantité de
sel augmente plus on déverse les eaux
usées denses et fleuves les habitants de
bassorah boivent littéralement non
seulement les eaux usées mais aussi
l'eau des drainages des fermes la
dilution était une solution à la
pollution mais ce n'est plus le cas il
n'y a pas assez d'eau pour la diluer la
cellule chénier la solution ne se trouve
pas en irak pour la trouver il faut
coopérer avec les pays voisins
prudence si nous ne commençons pas à
agir dès maintenant
l'été prochain sera dévastateur pour
bassorah et pour les grands marais
également
[Musique]
on
modèle à fuel à quelques minutes de vol
de bassorah le monde était étrangement
différents c'est comme si nous nous
trouvions à une autre époque et à la
messi au milieu des lacs et des marais
l'eau a créé un mode de vie particulier
en deux heures oui celui là ça ira
allons trouver un endroit où les bus ne
le feront pas tomber c'est le numéro un
d'accord oui monsieur et ce à deux
semaines ça fait deux ans maintenant
ou faut-il de m peut-être ici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu vois ces marqueurs chaque fois que
l'eau passe au niveau supérieur appelle
moi quand ça monte
appelle moi je contrôlerai le niveau de
l'eau
marc et d'une maison pota me ont été
séparés des autres terres la nature est
ici admirable la population locale vit
toujours comme il y à 3000 ou 4000 ans
s'il ya des oiseaux et des animaux que
vous ne trouverez nulle part ailleurs
je suis né dans les marais de
mésopotamie du sud de l'irak
il y avait environ 1200 îles la plus
grande étant habitée que par une dizaine
de familles les gens des marais vivait
dans une sorte d'état fantômes et évite
l état central par les habitants des
marais avait même des avantages car
l'ancien système obliger les gens à
servir à l'armée malgré marée était un
refuge pour eux ils pouvaient fuir sur
leur bateau et sans que personne puisse
les retrouver
ils ont élevé les buffles et pêcher
jusqu'à la fin de la guerre iran irak
[Musique]
les night in en 91
après la guerre du koweït où une révolte
a commencé en irak
elle a été écrasée et tous les rebelles
se sont réfugiés dans les marais pour
échapper à la colère de saddam hussein
en ce moment une bande de traîtres ont
infiltré le pays pour répandre le
terrorisme huisne pillages et
destructions
ils se sont implantés dans les villes et
villages de l'irak du sud
[Musique]
alida nos grands pères se souviennent de
leur grand père qui vivait dans les
marais cinq générations ou plus ont vécu
ici
en 1991 les gens ont manifesté
il y avait le parti dawa qui ne voulait
pas que sa dame reste au pouvoir ou
salés inciter les gens à se rebeller
lorsque l'armée de saddam a écrasé les
rebelles
le parti s'est enfui en iran et les
pauvres en ont payé le prix nous n'avons
pas participé à la révolte
mais nous avons été punis parce que les
rebelles s'étaient cachés dans les
marais parmi ceux qui sont restés
beaucoup ont été tués
certains ont réussi à s'échapper en
punition saddam s'est mis à assécher les
marais le gouvernement irakien a décidé
de consacrer tout le pib du pays à
l'assèchement des marais et faire en
sorte que le tigre et l'euphrate naike
vers bassorah et n'alimentent plus les
marais se démarre et ont donc été
complètement détruit complètement
asséché l'assèchement des marais a
provoqué une hausse de température de 5
degrés dans cette zone les tempêtes de
poussière sont devenues plus fréquentes
et la pêche a décliné catch mais dans un
monde où certains ni le changement
climatique dans un monde qui considère
que l'environnement engendre des coûts
supplémentaires dans une zone qui
recouvre les plus grandes réserves de
pétrole du monde
personne ne s'intéresse vraiment aux
barres et les marais ont été restaurés
en 2003 grâce à la volonté des locaux et
un peu des deux de notre part nous
avions de l'eau mais des barrières la
bloquer elles ont été brisées et l'eau
de l'euphrate et du tigre est revenu
[Musique]
le barrage construit pendant la
sécheresse des marais était trop pour
que les gens puissent creuser dedans
jassim et moi avons dit d'accord voici
500 $ à mener d'une pelleteuse
ils ont commencé à creuser une tranchée
puis l'eau a commencé à faire son propre
chemin vers les marais mais deux mois
plus tard quand je suis revenu il y
avait une forêt de roseaux c'était un
endroit incroyable
[Applaudissements]
après la chute de saddam en 2003 l'eau
est revenue
les gens ont commencé à élever du bétail
mais il y à un nouveau problème tu vas
prendre de l'eau aujourd'hui nous devons
apporter en bateau de l'eau pour les
animaux j'ai quarante buffle si un
buffle le bois l'eau de la rivière il
meurt cette eau est empoisonné elle est
salé amer
salle 1 2 mais buffon à vue puis est
mort nous avons le plus grand fleuve
l'euphrate l'année chaque jour nous
devons apporter de l'eau douce depuis la
ville pour nos buffle n'y a pas d'eau
nous mourrons tous aujourd'hui même à
bassorah les gens protestent car il n'y
a pas si nous n'avons pas d'eau non
avril auront même le pétrole n'auront
plus aucun sens l'eau et tout ce qui
importe réellement
[Applaudissements]
le marché les marais sont une partie
importante de mon passé formé et est
ingénieur en irrigation et il
travaillait comme un fou
l'un des rares souvenirs de moments où
j'étais seul avec lui remonte à l'époque
où il était parti pour les marais en
prétextant devoir vérifier les
structures de contrôle des inondations
alors qu'en réalité ils étaient
simplement aller à la chasse aux canards
c'était son os bien et maintenant
l'ironie du sort est que je manque
autant à mes enfants que mon père me
manquer naïvement je pensais que cela
prendrait de trois ans alors que ça fait
déjà 15 ans et demi que nous sommes en
irak
ça avait un prix la distance en quelque
sorte affecté notre mariage et
malheureusement il a pris fin mai mais
plus important que ça j'ai raté un
j'ai raté j'ai raté les anniversaires de
mes filles les soirées de fin d'études
fausse dès les premiers amours j'espère
que j'aurai quelque chose de positif à
leur montrer pour leur expliquer
pourquoi les choses se sont passées
ainsi
bon
tu es sûr que tu l'auras
dépêche-toi avant qu'il se noie
[Applaudissements]
et le soleil puisqu'il est arrivé au
chaud il est allé boire et puis il est
tombé quand nous avons vu qu'il était en
train de se noyer
j'ai sauté et je les sorties de l'eau
c'est un peu tard mais il va s'en
remettre mais le la et couvre le
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup d'animaux se noie ici ce sont
des eaux usées l'eau est sale elle vient
en partie de la rivière chatel arabe est
en partie des égouts elle a l'air propre
car la plupart de l'eau vient de la
rivière mais ce n'est pas le cas en
réalité elle est intégralement polluer
[Musique]
ou buvez de l'eau du robinet sinon elle
est salée on s'empoisonne ray encore
aujourd'hui même maintenant beaucoup de
gens ont été empoisonnés par cette eau
[Musique]
heiden heiland tu a vomi non je souffre
de diarrhées et de maux d'estomac
ça pourrait être non pas dix sites non
ce n'est pas ça ça fait mal ici
il n'a pas n'a pas dit comment est elle
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui mauvais mais après les
pluies la situation s'est un peu
améliorée
les habitants de bassorah souffre de
douleurs de maladies gastro intestinales
dans des proportions épidémiques
nous ne sommes pas censés avoir des
problèmes comme ça le nombre de patients
a diminué il est désormais entre 20 et
30 par jour nous craignons une épidémie
l'été prochain je parle d'une épidémie
de choléra
il a vomi fièvre monsieur une fièvre une
terrible diarrhée pas de fièvre depuis
combien de temps avez-vous la diarrhée
depuis trois jours les gens ont commencé
à quitter bassorah pour les pays voisins
franchement le pays nous a abandonnés je
vais pleurer je vais pleurer
on les pointe seulement 0,1 pour cent de
l'eau mondiale est douce et
renouvelables le reste ne l'est pas des
mâles la demande augmente mais surtout
le manteau neigeux diminue changement
climatique fait que l'horloge avance
plus rapidement
en fait une fois que lydie zoom va
commencer à se remplir
l'isu est le dernier barrages que la
turquie construit il n'y aura plus d'eau
pour beaucoup de villes il existe des
lois internationales interdisant aux
pays d'empêcher l'accès à l'eau à leurs
voisins essayer de les mettre en
application
et les questions de possession
représente 90% de la loi
mais
et
mieux vaut ne pas trop s'habiller de
toute manière je ne sais pas comment
m'habiller
je pense que le jeune va bien c'est un
peu neutre
ce n'est pas comme le rouge me ronge de
trump ils veulent parler de la crise de
l'eau pour savoir quoi faire
vous ne pouvez pas produire l'eau la
seule façon de résoudre le problème est
de parvenir à un accord avec la turquie
dans un premier temps et avec la syrie
et l'iran ensuite l'un des ministres qui
sera présent à la réunion a
essentiellement laissé entendre que je
voulais céder des droits naturels les
droits naturels de l'irak pour l'eau il
terminait son article en critiquant mes
idées en écrivant vive l'irak du mec
c'est bon le patriotisme ne réside pas
dans les slogans être patriote selon moi
c est penser aux problèmes qui peuvent
apparaître et les empêcher d'appareils
ne pas pleurer quand les problèmes
surviennent et dire au malheur à moi
c'est le changement climatique
on ne peut pas y faire quoi que ce soit
ainsi si mon vieux tu peux enfin bon je
ne veux pas être trop négatif et
peut-être que cet après midi je serai
totalement différent je serai absolument
déçu ou tout à fait exact et à mon dieu
nous avons un sauveur au cas où
quelqu'un l'embrasserai
[Musique]
allez au revoir les mecs
là bas c'est là que les eaux usées sont
déversées directement dans le tigre
lennar de manière amusante nous avons
justement discuté du fait que l'irak
utiliser le tigre et l'euphrate comme
des égouts à ciel ouvert la réunion a
été ouverte par le premier ministre qui
a expliqué que nous traversions une
crise
il était ouvert à la discussion car
chance j'ai dit il ne s'agit pas
seulement de négocier sur l'os et l'eau
l'électricité l'énergie et le commerce
est il ajouté
et l'agriculture et j'ai répondu vous
avez absolument raison mon intuition me
dit que ce premier ministre réfléchit
dans la bonne direction il pense aux
priorités
il attribue une valeur au marais et à
l'environnement
alors c'est une bonne journée
si le premier ministre doit agir
rapidement il devra trouver des astuces
dans le processus de négociation bien
sûr salle expose à des accusations de
corruption ce qui arrive souvent en irak
qu'il le fasse ou non ça semble mal
parti et je ne parle même pas des
questions budgétaires
mon dieu
je vous ai montré l'échantillon d'eau ok
donc c'est un échantillon d'eau qui
vient de reposer pendant une demi heure
et là je viens de le secouer c'est de
l'eau du robinet de bassorah elle a
prétendument été nettoyé et passer par
des clarificateur et du chlore et ya été
ajouté
c'est ce qui coule du robinet de breteil
à broder ya dans ma jeunesse était un
quartier de luxe à bassorah c'est là que
vivent les riches vivent et les
commerçants la salinité de l'eau de cet
échantillon dit 1858 alors qu'elles ne
devraient pas dépasser 1000 à 500 et
vous commencez à sentir le sel ce conte
résoudre ce problème il faut aller en
turquie et dire nous sommes censés être
de bons voisins vous devez nous louer il
y jouer et nous laissons y lisent ou
vides et les sons l'eau couler c'est la
seule solution qui pourrait marcher à
l'optimisme est de retour
peut-être que cette crise fera en sorte
que ma solution se concrétise encore
plus rapidement un crois mon dieu
[Musique]
vous faites en sorte que l'eau coule et
la nature se guérit d'elle-même
l'humanité n'a pas la volonté de guérir
cette ville c'est et bassora et aller de
mal en pis il a été redonné vie au
marais qui sont désormais florissant la
restauration est une sorte de symbole
pour l'ira gras mais fine le phénix
surgit littéralement descendre de la
guerre je savoure mais comme pour tout
en irak
c'est un pas en avant deux pas en
arrière trois pas en avant et un pas en
arrière
[Musique]
c'est
monde